o
eu queria queria aproveitar para
agradecer diz é o convite ea
oportunidade de estar aqui e vocês
também estarão presentes
antes de iniciar a minha carreira no
golfe paulo foi muito bem sucedido
estou verisign e quando estava a
terminar o meu curso de design em 2005
estava de fato triste com aquilo com a
sensação de que eu me tornar este dia ia
tornar se uma espécie de maquiadores ou
e 11 nista de um sistema de mercado um
sistema baseado nas finanças eu sentia
que o papel da comunicação era muito
esses fatos eu ia criar currículos ea
criar mentiras ia criar propaganda e
alimentar ainda mais o sistema e então
na altura am eu decidi criar uma espécie
de contraponto à e pensar dentro daquilo
que eu sei fazer de facto era comunicar
ampliar uma espécie de novo logo uma
espécie de r marca dentro de segundas
marcas proposta tinha vindo quem está na
cidade e por que acreditar e sendo que
de facto de algum modo queremos
perturbar um ser com algum sistema tem
que ser com seu interior
a idéia é criar esse contraponto sur e
surge o mais - ou mais - no fundo acaba
por ser ilustração do estudo
a expressão desses mundos do mundo daqui
uns têm mais de 500 atendimentos
o mundo basicamente livre debaixo de uma
sombra econômica e financeira mais
comuns e ao mesmo tempo sendo é essa a
parte da comunicação em energia com
móveis mundo e entre os que esta pequena
emoção a mais - qualquer matemática já
que vai dizer mais ou menos igual a
menos nos primeiros mais - a igual a
zero é a anulação desse sistema e então
com esta pequena equação eu preferi ir
para a rua e ir para a rua
ver de que forma é que a comunicação ea
propaganda facto enchia com as pessoas
então decidi utilizar o porto na minha
cidade natal
quase como um laboratório onde eu fiz
essa experiência e de espalhar por
diversos esportes urbanos por todo lado
forma viral ou mais - e cobre todas as
superfícies possíveis e no fundo alterar
um pouco aquilo que tínhamos aqui o que
era o panorama urbano e foi por esse foi
tal modo incisivo em tão poucos meses é
que não só as pessoas ficaram com imensa
curiosidade que seria mais - pouco mais
- no fundo é um produto nesta sós
publicitava é o mesmo e não vende
mentiras como também chama a atenção dos
media e então depois de ver esse impacto
se ver esse impacto seria mais uma vez e
com a rua sim salvaria e então foi fazer
inquéritos anônimos sem dizer só que as
pessoas na rua e perguntarem se tinham
visto algum símbolo alguma marca nova
que não conseguiam perceber de fato 70%
das pessoas falavam mais - aquelas que
não falavam muito vai e terminavam
queridos aquelas que falavam eu
continuava inquérito e então cria
perceber que tipo de reação aquilo que
as pessoas achavam de forma que ela se
aproveitavam
neste símbolo tão incógnita e também por
ter as reações mas e técnicas
passada essa primeira fase do projeto eu
percebi perdão eu percebi então que mais
- funcionava quase como uma espécie de
teste do chaves utilizavam mais - como
uma uma tela em branco onde estavam os
seus medos as sociedades as suas
angústias seus anjos
então percebi que realmente essa força
que a comunicação tinha e qual é o papel
dela
sete anos depois já em 2012
fui convidado para capital europeia da
cultura em guimarães e teve de fazer uma
performance que ficou conhecida como o
enterro de portugal e ele ficou
conhecida por que acabou por ter um
grande impacto porque eu vou poder por
acrescentar ela por agentes exteriores
ao projeto acrescentar ainda mais esta
performance e possuía foi o último saque
mais uma vez percebi a força que ainda
sentirá tem no mundo ou nunca existiram
tantas marcas tantas identidades
nunca vi as pessoas estão pouco
referenciados ea verdade é que o impacto
que com esta performance teve fez com
que o comando geral da guarda nacional
republicana
se eles se juntarão mais - e continuará
por formas e foi o que fizeram porque
com 37 guardas da guarda nacional para
irem à frente desta marcha e um coronel
acabou por ser ignorado
e agora estava a passar o vídeo por
favor
à primeira vista pode parecer que tudo
se estão a apresentação acontece por aí
que guarda de honra é mesmo real
o chef membros da guarda nacional
republicana que contam um caixão de
portugal são verdades guardas não seria
contratado pela organização para
participarem no projecto teatral
o enterro de portugal é contínua 17 de
agosto e foi uma das iniciativas da
capital do país de cultura guimarães
só que esta participação especial da gnr
caso mal estar na instituição
o vovô abertura de um processo de
demissões que terminou agora com isso
ressaltou o comandante territorial de
braga apesar de existir uma autorização
genérica para a participação da guarda
em eventos de iniciativa cultural
o comandante terá considerado que este
em particular não se enquadrava nesse
contexto o grupo laboratório foi nós que
ensinou a apresentação já lamentou a
decisão da gnr afirma que o chefe
membros da guarda foram pagos tal qual
acontece no jogo de futebol
o objetivo do funeral era alertar para a
situação do país com criatividade do
sindae o plano também a ressurreição
hernâni carvalho muito votar e agora que
está uma questão é polêmica é tem que
várias questões aliás não é só uma
história exatamente uma das questões
interessantes é fazer o funeral num no
âmbito de uma das composições
brasileiras para hoje presidente da
república mas agora a três anos e com
essa idéia de criar os desafios querem
que o jardim prossegue desde o início do
projeto é criar esta tela onde as
pessoas pudessem projetar eu queria
largar o projeto sertanejo
depois virão já uma das formas com já
contra outro corpo mais importantes na
rua e eu fui criando ensaios e foi
criando de autos foi grande alguns com
as pessoas forma aqui
elas próprias também pudessem intervir
de alguma forma com o projeto e esse de
alguns foram importantes para me fazer
perceber algumas questões para trazer as
pessoas para os debates que o jogo seria
essencial e certo dia achei que devia
ovários mais longe e então queria criar
os cerca de 300 escritórios espalhados
numa praça tirar as letras das paredes e
janelas as pessoas e desafiar as pessoas
para escreverem no futuro as pessoas iam
escrevendo mensagens na praça outros
utilizando os critérios e andavam o
secretário um ato outros deixavam sua
mensagem posso tudo e às mensagens que o
parceiro for realmente em três anos
e foi exatamente o que se ver de que
forma quando a praça estava cheia de
mensagens novas pessoas não se rende
tinham que tirar do futuro das outras
para fazer o seu próprio futuro e quase
como uma visão poética e cisnes o quanto
o futuro dos outros é importante para o
nosso futuro também
e como deve ser construir em conjunto é
bom por vezes também perceber que os
outros vão buscar só ao nosso trabalho
criam de altos conosco e alguns de alte
nós não estamos à espera como aconteceu
neste caso uma companhia teatro como
trip utilizaram uma intervenção a lidar
no uma peça feita por elas
mas nem tudo são rosas por isso recebi
mensagens - menos interessantes algumas
pessoas como está aqui uma ameaça e diz
que deve vender seus papéis mais - e vós
este ano porque a ética
certo dia estava em uma manifestação em
frente à assembleia da república e
aprovados etapa capaz de comer certo
mais - e uma conversa com ele para a
vontade porque eu tenho aquela certo e
vai deixar de dizer não estamos a pensar
estou compreendendo ética eu comprasse
energética hoje é semente falamos de 50
ou mais - a venda é óbvio muito
provavelmente nada tem a ver com o
projeto
mais - mas agora está aqui
e propus que os vendidos em excesso de
médicos provavelmente encontra quanto a
deus mas não quiseram falar comigo ideal
ficou por aqui
depois há outros de altos aviadas
inspirados como neste caso
paulo portas é o vice-primeiro-ministro
portugal certo dia receber esta mensagem
e partilhei nas redes sociais
certo dia uma segunda mensagem eu vou
ter partilhado nas redes sociais que
ninguém acreditava que paulo portas
tivesse tamanha intimidade comigo eu
tivesse tal modo impensado no meu
trabalho
talvez sim talvez não mas muito vir água
até que aparece uma terceira mensagem e
nesta terceira mensagem além que no celf
deu ali no reflexo daquela peça
curiosamente é uma mistura entre a
bandeira portuguesa ea vanguarda na qual
é uma proposta pra valer a portuguesa do
século 21
e aqui as pessoas ficaram confusas já
não sabemos qual portas não conheciam e
mais tarde a durante estes brios de
intervenções que foi fazendo por ruas
a minha principal intenção foi sempre
criar um discurso fazendo criar estes de
alvos e pôr as pessoas a pensar em criar
e estimular o pensamento crítico
eu acho que esse é um dos papéis da área
porque os extremos contorná las ou até
desafiá las mas é importante darmos as
pessoas a pensarem
é esse o meu desafio é um desafio de
olharmos com as coisas de outra forma e
ter usado de tudo registrar essas
mudanças e o ponto em que nos
encontramos hoje em dia e é por isso que
eu acredito numa altura de chefes do
consumo e criamos valor a coisas que se
calhar não são assim tão importante ser
a nossa função contornar essas idéias e
construímos um caminho um caminho que
estamos todos os usuários em conjunto em
papai noel
a verdade é que este sistema está
saturado olhos vistos
estamos no primeiro lance tivemos
realmente um prêmio muito importante da
nossa história e entretanto temos essa
consciência temos essa consciência
global que está a acontecer à nossa
sociedade se constrói é preciso
abandonar os bebês até que fontes é que
ela aguenta o sistema e eu vou tentar
fazer a melhor arma suas palavras é uma
caneta é motas pra isso são as vozes que
é isso que temos que tomar um caminho
não viu entre um caminhão e um caminho
que faz a vida das pessoas que é preciso
realmente mudar alguma coisa e eu
percebi isso mais uma vez quase dez anos
depois começaram os projetos que não
tinha nada
porque tive a certeza que aquilo que era
realmente importante é que nós não
conseguimos apalpar é que não
conseguimos velho e foi nada
como vou tomar uma decisão aparentemente
difícil mas fácil para mim foi destruir
um bom trabalho no final do ano passado
por que eu iria trocar o conforto de uma
agência de comunicação em lisboa para
seguir aqui um realmente minha alma quer
isto o mais mente com s com esse
trabalho e cheguei mais uma vez que
estes dez anos depois outra pequena
porção muito importante que é a seguinte
eu prefiro criar nada e mudar alguma
coisa do criar alguma coisa e não usar
nada
e eu normalmente termina aqui as
conferências mas hoje tive a sorte de
ficar até o final e na hora do almoço de
fazer uma pequena pela creche
a minha apresentação porque hoje sentir
sede e concluir ao já muito importante
foi eu cheguei ontem em lisboa e as 6
mil quilômetros mas ao menos se
distancia do meu país eu senti
estamos realmente a caminhar para essa
consciência global
sentindo a sua estiveram aqui em cima e
sentindo a sessão de fado e isso é muito
importante sentir também que qualquer
sistema qualquer forma se o governo pode
ser destruída mas uma idéia uma idéia
dura para sempre
obrigado a votar